HE HAS TWO GOALS HE WANTS BACK
AND WE GOT DARCY KUEMPER TOP. CR
WAS THI.
BACKHANDED SAVE BY KUEMPER.
THAT'S HIS FIRST OF THE GAME.
[ WW
>> I TOOK ONE IN
HE DRAW.
WEEGAR.
CROSSBAR.AWAY.
BIG SLAP SHOT DEFLECTION IN SHOO
THE NET, STOPPED BY NICHUSHKIN
AND IT.
I'M MONTOUR.
THERE'S A BROKEN STICK AND A
PENALTY IS COMING UP AS PLAYER.E
CIRCLE.
AVS GOT A STICK OFF.
SAVE
BY DARRSKY KUEMPER!
HE GOES RIGHT TO THE TOP OF HIS.
MIKKO SENDS IT OFF. SWEPT
SHOT SAVED BY BOBROVSKY AS HE
IT ALMOST SLIDES --
MacKINNON TAKES THE ONE-TIMER
HE ANDRE
BURAKOVSKY ON THE POWER PLAY!WH.
OH.
HE
BACKHANDED, SAVED BY
RIGHT
HERE.
THAT WAS A TAKEDOWN BY
HE WILL RACE IN WITH
MacKINNON.
SHOTERE.
THIS IS THE SHOT SCORES.
ABLE TO RAM ITIF THIS GOES ABOV.
BRANDON MONTOUR FILLED IN ANDANG
TO GET BACK. FROM ANDRE
BURAKOVSKY!
HE PUTS THE AVS ON HIM.
MacKINNON PUSHES AFOR NEWHOOK I.
PUCK IS FREE DOWN LOW, RANTANENE
FLORIDA ZONE.
HERE'S BURAKOVSKY, SHOOO
BANGED UP TOP 15 TON IT UPIK JOT
PUCK